la parole est à monsieur alain dufau et
pour deux minutes pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'éducation
nationale de l'enseignement supérieur de
la recherche
très récemment madame le ministre un
magazine national magazine très connu a
mis en ligne sur internet une vidéo
intitulée les enfants à l'école de 10
lames tourné cette vidéo dans une salle
municipale d'avignon
apparemment cette salle municipale a été
mis à disposition par la mairie
d'avignon dans le cadre du dispositif d
enseignement de langue et culture
d'origine
le dispositif elco ce dispositif prend
appui sur une directive européenne du
conseil du 25 juillet 1977 visant bien
sûr à la scolarisation des enfants des
travailleurs migrants
il a été mis en oeuvre sur la base
d'accords bilatéraux entre la france et
plusieurs états de l'union européenne du
maghreb et du moyen orient
dispensée à partir du cours élémentaire
par des enseignants recrutés formés et
rémunérés par leur gouvernement
respectif
ce dispositif vient complément de
l'enseignement normal notamment sur un
créneau dévolu théoriquement autant
d'activités périscolaires
l'objectif de ce dispositif à l'origine
était de favoriser bien sûr le retour au
pays des enfants d'immigrés cependant
cet enseignement tel qu'il est pratiqué
aujourd'hui détourner l'esprit de la loi
dès lors qu'ils s'adressent à des
enfants de deuxième ou de troisième
génération qui n'ont pas pour objectif
de retourner dans leur pays d'origine
et force est de constater avec l'appui
de cette vidéo qui a été largement
diffusé aujourd'hui
ce dispositif offre pas les garanties
suffisantes sur ces contenus
pédagogiques et favorise le
communautarisme alors qu'en cette
période que nous traversons il
conviendrait plus que jamais de
promouvoir et garantir l'intégration de
ses enfants
alors madame la ministre à l'heure où
nous devons en effet plus que jamais
être vigilant et crier notre attachement
au principe de laïcité afin de préserver
l'ordre républicain
quelles mesures comptez vous prendre
pour réviser ou supprimer au plus tôt ce
dispositif qui est de toute évidence
détourne sa fonction d'origine pour vous
répondre la parole et aux milices de
l'éducation nationale merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur les sénateurs du faux
merci pour votre question je vais vous
répondre précisément sur les locaux mais
permettez moi juste de dire en deux mots
que votre question au fond complète bien
celle de madame la sénatrice morin
desailly puisqu'elle me permet à moi de
compléter mon propos de tout à l'heure
je disais notre politique en matière de
langues vivantes et d'apprentissage des
langues vivantes c'est une plus grande
précocité pour que les élèves les
apprennent plus tôt et mieux c'est
également une plus grande diversité des
langues vivantes apprise à l'école et y
compris à l'école primaire et j'ai
annoncé il ya quelques mois que pour la
rentrée prochaine nous aurions 1200
écoles primaires de plus dans notre pays
qui offrirait une autre langue que
l'anglais en apprentissage de élevé une
ce qui est vraiment un beau progrès que
nous allons continuer j'en viens aux
locaux
parce que bien sûr tout cela a partie
liée les locaux qu'est ce que c'est vous
l'avez rappelé des conventions
bilatérales qui ont été passées dans les
années 70 centres notre pays un certain
nombre de pays étrangers pour permettre
à des professeurs de ces pays étrangers
de venir apprendre la langue d'origine
à des élèves qui arrivent et qui
s'installer ici venant de ces pays
c'est convention c'est vrai vous avez
raison on fait long feu et elle mérite
d'être transformés vraiment et c'est ce
sur quoi je travaille depuis plus d'un
an maintenant car cela nécessite une
négociation bilatérale pays par pays que
j'ai commencé à mener avec plusieurs
pays pour revoir ces conventions et pour
faire en sorte que désormais
l'apprentissage de ces langues l'arabe
le portugais l'italien le turc etc se
fasse dans un cadre plus banales comme
on apprend l'anglais comme on apprend
l'allemand comme on apprend l'espagnol
est que ce soit la réalité des
prochaines années de notre pays pour
réaliser cela il faut donc revoir les
conventions une à une
j'arriverai pour la rentrée 2016 à
revoir celle avec le maroc et celle avec
le portugal
ce qui est déjà une belle
expérimentation qui pourra commencer
pour faire en sorte que les professeurs
qui donne ses cours dans les langues en
question fassent partie intégrante de
l'équipe pédagogique d
un glissement scolaire que le programme
de leurs cours soient contrôlés qu'il
soit même inspecté et que les élèves
obtiennent une évaluation une
certification de leurs compétences dans
ces langues qui leur permettent de les
conti au collège
voilà ce que nous commençons à la
rentrée 2016 avec ces deux pays qui ont
accepté de faire le premier pas et nous
nous donnons jusqu'à 2018 pour l'avoir
fait avec tous les pays concernés par
les locaux et qu'on change enfin deux
systèmes
merci